In a perfect world, every awesome video game
idea would become a reality…but our world
isn't perfect, and many sure-fire hit games
never make it past the beta stage.
It's a shame to lose out on the copious amounts
of sheer fun many of these games would've
generated.
So, let's sift through the scrapyard of canceled
games and pick out some buried treasures.
"Woah!
Nice graphics!
I'd like to get my hands on that game!"
Gotham by Gaslight
Batman plus anything usually equals success.
Well… almost anything.
Based on the comic book of the same name,
Gotham by Gaslight would've been no different.
Players took control of Steampunk Batman,
roaming Victorian England in search of Jack
the Ripper.
Why Jack?
Because after dealing with the Joker for so
long, it's sometimes good to relax with an
easier foe.
Sadly, Day One Studios, the company behind
Gotham by Gaslight, was unable to sell publisher
THQ on a free-roaming Batman game where Bruce
goes toe-to-toe with one of the most infamous
killers in history.
Gaslight Batman lives on in Lego Batman 3:
Beyond Gotham, Arkham Origins, and Infinite
Crisis, among others, all of which let you
play as the Victorian-era Dark Knight to your
heart's desire.
Highlander
Games based on TV shows and movies are hit-or-miss,
to say the least, but Highlander looked like
it would've been a hit.
Your exploits as an Immortal would've sent
you throughout history to locales like Ancient
Rome, Pompeii, and New York City…
Kind of like playing all of the Assassin's
Creed games at once, minus the crappy sequels.
You'd also get to perform all sorts of cool
death-defying stunts, like leaping down skyscrapers
or electrocuting yourself, without actually
dying.
They even had an actual writer from the Highlander
TV series to write the project.
Sadly, Square Enix themselves did the butchering,
cancelling the game in 2010 for unknown reasons.
The studio was probably too busy dragging
its feet with the next Final Fantasy or Kingdom
Hearts to set aside a weekend and just finish
Highlander already.
Hi-Ten Bomberman
If you enjoy mindless party games as much
as you love fiery explosions, Hi-Ten Bomberman
would have been your jam.
It was going to be regular Bomberman on steroids,
allowing up to 10 people to play at once.
Either against each other, in groups, or—if
anyone's feeling particularly sadistic—nine
vs. one.
More Bombers, more bombs, and more explosions—who
could ask for anything more?
Unfortunately, Hi-Ten Bomberman never went
anywhere, aside from a few Japanese video
game conventions in 1993.
Now that we have ultra-HD and online multiplayer,
why not give it another go?
In a society that still actively enjoys turning
each other into crispy critters, Hi-Ten Bomberman
would be a smash hit today.
B.C.
In Intrepid Computer Entertainment's B.C.,
you control a tribe of Neanderthals on a quest
to kill anyone not in your tribe, thereby
evolving the human race in your image.
Along the way, you have to battle angry apes
and gigantic, man-eating dinosaurs, both of
whom hate everything about you except your
rich, meaty flavor.
Sadly, B.C. was simply too ambitious.
Planned features included changing weather,
an epic food chain, independently functioning
NPCs, and the ability to choose who to let
into your tribe.
The project was cancelled in 2004, but in
the modern gaming scene, B.C. would fit right
in, and likely be among the best.
Insane
Lots of us love survival horror games, so
imagine somebody who truly knows horror giving
it a shot.
This would have been the case with Insane,
a 2012 game directed by Guillermo del Toro
of Hellboy and Pan's Labyrinth fame.
Insane was to be the most terrifying sandbox
game of all time.
Plus, del Toro had an entire trilogy in mind.
Financial difficulties forced THQ to focus
solely on guaranteed hits, however, rather
than experimental horror projects.
Currently, del Toro owns all the rights to
Insane, so he could always make it a reality
with another game company, or simply turn
it into a badass movie franchise…
Provided he's not too busy explaining why
Hellboy 3 still isn't happening.
Silent Hills
Another abandoned Guillermo del Toro project,
Silent Hills was supposed to be the director’s
collaboration with Metal Gear series creator
Hideo Kojima.
Add The Walking Dead’s Norman Reedus and
you have a guaranteed win.
This trifecta of legendary figures would have
made for an incredible psychological horror
experience on the PS4, but it was sadly canceled.
Rumors had it that Kojima was leaving Konami,
which was why the project was pulled.
P.T., the playable teaser for the game, was
pulled from the PlayStation Store as well,
but you can still relive the terror if you
kept the demo in your library.
Sadly, it's the closest you'll ever get to
Silent Hills.
Star Wars 1313
As a young Boba Fett, Star Wars 1313 would
allow you to navigate the wretched hive of
scum and villainy that is the underground
Coruscant, where there are no Jedi to keep
the peace.
1313 focused almost entirely on guns, blasters,
and whatever else a bounty hunter would need
to get his dirty job done.
Unfortunately, this amazing concept couldn't
survive the one thing more evil than the Dark
Side: corporate takeovers.
When Disney bought the Star Wars franchise
in 2012, it cancelled anything LucasArts had
in the pipeline, including 1313.
Current Star Wars game publisher, EA, has
shown little interest in 1313, preferring
to focus on more mainstream, canonical games
like Battlefront.
LucasArts, meanwhile... has given us Angry
Birds Star Wars II.
Star Wars 1313 is left somewhere in the junkyard,
likely near Luke Skywalker's dismembered hand.
Mega Man Universe
Mega Man is awesome.
That’s pretty much just science.
Know what would have been even more awesome?
The ability to make your own levels and customize
your very own Mega Man.
Just think Mario Maker.
That was the premise for Mega Man Universe,
a side-scrolling platformer that was supposed
to be released on Xbox Live Arcade and the
PlayStation Network.
We would have loved to have seen what kind
of sick, twisted platforming gauntlets creative
players could have shared online if this game
came to fruition.
And even cooler was the fact that Ryu from
Street Fighter and Arthur from Ghosts 'n Goblins
were planned as DLC characters.
Sadly, the game was cancelled in 2011, so
now we only have our super fighting robot
dreams to hang onto.
Star Fox 2
Releasing a direct sequel to the original
Star Fox on the Super Nintendo would have
been a no-brainer, but it didn't work out
that way.
Star Fox 2 would have continued the story
and reassembled the original team to fight
Emperor Andross and protect the Lylat system,
including new ships and new characters.
Unfortunately, the arrival of the Nintendo
64 stopped development on the title, although
Japanese versions of the prototype leaked
online in 2015.
It might not have seen the light of day as
an official Super Nintendo game, but Star
Fox 2 is alive out there somewhere, and we'd
still love to barrel roll through it.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
lost games you’d like to play...